everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we are in round 8 of
our coverage
the 2016 Singh field cup our competitors
today Levon Aronian playing the white
pieces he is our defending champion
although he hasn't had the best
tournament so far he's in the middle of
the pack and then we also have Nakamura
playing the black pieces this is the 5th
and 6th ranked player in the world
facing off Nakamura kind of in the same
boat that Levon Aronian is there in the
middle of pack definitely looking to get
a victory here to propel them with the
last day tomorrow they want to be up
near the top of the leaderboard to make
as much money as possible and just to
earn those much-needed point in the
grand prix so we get started with Levon
Aronian pawn to a d4 Knight to f6 pond
c4 pawn e6 Knight f3 pawn down to d5 and
then Knight c3 so the Queens gambit a
climb line getting there from a little
bit different variation as we usually
see in the Queens gambit declined line
Bishop ear to e7 a Bishop f4 always like
in the Queen's game decline line before
you play pawn here to e3 getting a dark
square Bishop involvement of the game it
can be a very very difficult task if you
play pawn to e4 or pawn to e3 to ever
get your dark square Bishop involved so
doing that early makes a lot of sense
guys on the kingside pawn here to e3
pawn c5 we do see some exchange off the
board Bishop down here c5 Bishop d3 pawn
takes the bishop rook captures pawn here
to a6 and then Bishop back here to d3
but if you look at both sides of the
board we almost have a mirror match
going on now this dark square bishop is
a little bit more involved into the game
and you'll see that coming to play as
this light square bishop has a hard time
getting activated because it did not
come out before the pawn here to e6 but
both sides with a similar setup and then
pawn here to 86 from nock more change
things up a little bit Bishop back here
to d3 Knight c3 Bosa or c6 both sides
just continuing their development castle
on the King side and the knight to b4 so
knocker more is the first one to really
extend his pieces and really start and
attack on his opponents side of the
board it's not here to b4 bishop comes
back here to b1
you just don't see the bishop on b1 very
often but now we see an exchange on
board the Queen unto the one rook
recaptures and then Knight to d5 white
takes on d5 Knight recaptures on d5 and
the bishop up here to e4 so both sides
looking fairly good in the center the
board black does have to worry about
getting his light squared bishop
involved into the board so that's kind
of his next act that he's gonna be
looking to do and that up here to f6
Knights here to d2 and then rook to e8 I
really don't like the rook to e8 to move
I don't know that it's terrible just me
personally I feel like Knight taking on
e4 is much more important this bishop
this like super bishop is a huge pain
for nakamora to deal with this pawn
can't move because the rook would fall
the bishop can't move because the pawn
would fall and so the entire Queen side
just kind of stuck there and as soon as
the root comes here to e8 all of a
sudden Bishop back here to f3 and it's
just lying down on the Queen side of the
board usually you know from White's
perspective his bishops are looking on
the Kings side but he recognizes here he
has a strong attack on the Queen side so
both this light square bishop and dark
square bishop just eyeing down on the
Queen side so for that reason I think
just go ahead and get off your your
knight have an exchange that's fine I'm
born you could see the Knights or after
the knight comes back here to d2 Knight
takes here on e4
after the knight captures here Bishop
back here to a7 I think this is gonna be
completely fine for Nakamura but in the
game he decided to play rook to e8
Bishop back to f3 as we talked about
kind of kind of a pain for black to deal
with pawn here to e5 Bishop back here to
g3 and then a rook to a7 that's kind of
one of those awkward moves where this
doesn't really do all that much except
it does allow him to free up his Bishop
finally move his palm but usually don't
wait playing rook 287 just so you can
move your pawn rook over here to c1 and
Levon Aronian is doing a good job
whenever you have your rooks you want
them to control
been files right now the C and the D
file are open and he's controlling both
of those what with his rooks Nakamura on
the other hand one who works here on a
seven not doing anything and the other
rook here on ei tit is behind upon which
eventually we want to have in the
endgame pushing for right now it's not
doing too much except playing defense so
I'd much rather be in White's
perspective right now being a being the
aggressor on board pun here to b6
getting that pawn in bottoms of the
action is we've talked about pawn a3
Bishop here d7 night c4 just getting
involved into the center of the board a
little bit pawn to e4 pawn back here our
bishop back here e to pawn a five and
then Knight up here to a d6 attacking
the rook says hey if you want to go
ahead and exchange your Bishop give me
the double Bishop air that's fine it
decides to play rook here to e7 and then
rook b5 attacking the rook the rook
decides not to move on and instead we do
see an exchange on board so Levon
Aronian has a pretty good setup he has
the double bishop pair that's a check
that's always gonna be good especially
in an open game like this where there's
not a lot of pawns clogging up the
center of the board and also has the
rooks controlling the central file so
all in all white has a really good setup
knock more needs to find a way to get
some sort of attack going Luke a 8 and
then King to F 1 now that the double
bishop pair from blacks off the board
and the Queen's off the board Levon
erroneous eyes now's a good time to
start getting his keen involved into the
actions King here to F one rook here to
e6 King up e 2 and then pawn to g5 so
recognizing that his opponent pretty
much has the domination on the Queen
side he starts to push forward a little
bit on the King side Bishop back c4
attacking the rook rook back to e8 and
then pawn up here to h4 we do see an
exchange over here on the Kings side so
it's gonna be interesting to see if any
side brings the rook over to h1 tries to
sneak in behind the defense on the
center of the board it's going to be
much easier for white
to get behind enemy lines really start
to attack and put a lot of pressure on
his opponents pieces but you could
definitely see King here to g7 swinging
the recover here to h8 bring it down to
h2 even behind enemy lines rook to h1 if
we if Nakamura decides to go ahead and
go that route Bishop up here d6 King g7
Bishop b5 attacking the rook we do now
see an exchange on board after rook
takes on d6 the rook is forced to move
but now the rook swings over here to b6
and von Aronian goes up a pawn and
material so his continuation that he
found was really nice and that he gave
him an extra pawn and he found a way to
activate his rook really really nice
play from Levon Aronian his goal is
gonna be to hang on to this material and
eventually use his bishop to gobble up
some more material when you get to the
in-game bishops usually do better if
there's pawns on both sides of the board
Knights normally do better if there's
pawns on one side of the board since
there's pawns on both sides of the board
I definitely give an even bigger
advantage to white with the bishop there
Luke over here to h8 we said that might
be a possibility rook to b7 getting it
on the seventh rank is always important
and if you're black usually want to get
that down on to the second rank rook
here to f5 rook over here f1 protecting
the pawn here on f2 and then it broke
down here to h2 so this is good bring it
down here to h2 unfortunately it missed
a big attack here with Bishop to c4 he
probably should have just played King to
g6 Denis Bishop here to G c4 Knight g4
probably makes a lot of sense but in the
game they played rook down here h2
Bishop c4 Knight up here to e7 there is
if you can kind of see it here the
bishop and the rook are both attacking
the pawn so the Knights kind of forced
to move with a discovered defense with a
rook here on f5 protecting the pawn here
on f7 and then work down here b5
attacking
rook rook takes and then the wool the
bishop recaptures attacking the knight
Knight comes down here to d6 and then
kind of the move that puts it all
together and that is Bishop up here to
d7 this is just a really good move
because now of a sudden this protects
although it doesn't look like it
actually protects from rook over here to
g2 because then you just see rook to d1
attacking the knight the Knights forced
to move after the knight moves then rook
over here to h1 stops this rook from
being able to go anywhere can't come
here to do you want it's captured can't
come here to g3 its capture can't come
here to g4 it would be captured from the
bishop and there's no way to really stop
this if we see King to g6 then just
Bishop down here to h3 the rook is going
to fall if instead we were to see pawn
to g4 trying to stop this a little bit
then King to f1 and then Knight
potentially over here to e3 sacrificing
pawn takes on e3 rook over here B 2 and
then rook to a g1 getting ready to
gobble up more material yes he did hold
onto his rook but White has the bishop
and he's gonna be able to gobble up
material and he shouldn't lose any more
material if he doesn't want to just play
pawn here to a4 it is being protected by
the bishop could even bring it down here
to b5 I just kind of have these pawn and
Bishop holding on to each other so all
in all this would be a terrible mistake
good news for Nakamura he decides not to
do that instead he decides to play that
King to f6 and then rook over here C 1 a
rook back here to H a so he brought it
down here to h2 wanted to have a strong
attack but he he just didn't have it so
he decided to retreat in that position
pawn here to b3 a king here to e7
attacking the bishop and then Ric up
here to c7 adding a little more
protection and an attack on the black
side nakamora plays rook h1 trying to
get behind enemy lines rook to a7 and
then Rick over here a 1y continues with
pawn to g4 and then the rook recaptures
I just really don't like this
he has the potential discovered attack
with [ __ ] up here to g4 and then after
the King moves now the rook can play
rook a8 if he wants to in between move
and then take the pawn here on a5 and
his pawn on a3 is not going to fall now
in the game we saw that instead of the
bishop coming down discovered attack we
see pawn up here to g4 now after the
rook takes on a3 Bishop comes down here
a4 discovered attack he is able to gain
that material on a5 but you can see that
his pawn did fall in a3 so I think he
could have gone up a little bit more
material but all-in-all this is still a
fine position he's still up upon still
has the better minor piece the bishop
over the night since there's the pawn
here and you can just control so much of
the board right here rook back here a
two king f1 pawn f6 rook over here to a8
we do see a nice little attack here on
the king rook here b2 rook a7 just
forcing the king to move exactly wants
to and then eventually we see Bishop
here at five discovered attack and then
King to e8 and this stops the king from
ever getting past this seventh rank for
the time being unless the night were to
move in front of the rook and stop that
but this does limit the mobility that
black has and then after that move we
see the Bishop come back here to e6 this
is kind of the setup that Levon Aronian
wanted because this is a very
centralized initiative it's protecting
the pawn the pawn doesn't have to do
much at all and at the same time as we
said this King on EA it's not going to
be coming past the seventh ranked rook
here to be one king a g29 save square
rook here b2 and then Bishop d5 so it's
just centralizing a little bit still
protecting this pawn here on b3 gearing
up for an attack if you wants to on e4
next move is someone odd and that's rook
to be won
I think it's probably better to get it
on the Open File rook here to see - I'll
be decided to play rook to be one Bishop
c6 attacking
King rook over here d7 says hey you can
take my pawn now but I'm gonna go ahead
and take your knight Knight up here to
f7
Bishop takes on e4 says you can go ahead
and capture if you want to but it's
gonna be bad you can't take on b3 now
because rook takes King takes bishop
here to d5 check the rooks going to fall
three pawns at a bishop against two
pawns is a very very easy in game for
world cast player so in the game we saw
rook to a b2 rook over here b7
protecting that Knight to d6 rook up
here ba check and then we see kind of
the same thing before Bishop here d5 but
all of a sudden that pawn here on e4 is
gone so White's doing a good job of
gobbling up material and proving his his
position along the way rook here d2
attacking the bishop pawn to e4 is a
nice little move it forces getting into
the endgame exactly how Levon Aronian
wants it because this is very tough for
black to deal with the pond and the
bishop in the center of the board
there's just no real good way to attack
this pawn to f5 we see the pawn capture
here the knight takes on f5 now to get
this material the bishops going to fall
but that's gonna be completely okay rook
here to b7 kind of an in-between move
now we see exactly the position of our
honor Levon Aronian once now after the
pawn takes on f5 the bishops going to
fall but there's no way to really stop
the threat of all these passed pawns F
pawn is pushed the past is past you can
start to push it this pawn here on b3
you can start to push it so all now it's
gonna be a very difficult came for
knocking more to even hold on for a draw
the good news for Nakamura he does
continue to play out so many players
would resign in this position but he
says hey you know what I only have one
day left in the tournament let's
continue to play it out rook here to d4
King g3 King g6 pushing up f7 getting
ready to promote pawn appear b4 this
works doing a good job of protecting
both of his pawns King f8 so it's not
going to be doing too much just staying
up here
fate and then rook over here be for pawn
at B six and now it is time to get the
King involved in to the game and there's
no way to really stop this on board the
runner Levon Aronian just marches his
king up and then eventually on board
Nakamura decides hey once the rule comes
here to a7 he's going to be able to get
his King involved passes pushes pawn up
to b8 and it's going to be game over so
Nakamura Falls Levon Aronian last year's
champion wins moves him up in to the top
of the leaderboard although he is not in
first I don't think he's gonna be
winning this one but he's definitely
near the top so congratulations to Levon
Aronian with a well deserved victory
thank you guys for watching around
eights we do have one more round
tomorrow so definitely look out for that
one but thanks again I'll see you guys
in the next round